- [Instructor] We're told that Eric
is shorter than Priti.
Priti is 158 centimeters tall.
Write an inequality that
compares Eric's height
in centimeters, E, to Priti's height.
Pause this video and
see if you can do that.
Alright, so we have Eric's height,
which we are using the
variable capital E for,
And how does it compare?
It says Eric is shorter than Priti.
So Eric's height is going to be less than
whatever Priti's height is,
which is 158 centimeters.
You could think about
it on a number line too.
If I were to draw a number line like this,
and this is 158
centimeters, Priti's height,
Eric's is gonna be less than
that 'cause he is shorter.
So it would be all of the
values that are to the left of,
let me do this in another color,
that are less than that.
Just like that.
Let's do another example.
Here we are told that Sydney wears skirts
when the temperature is warmer
than 25 degrees Celsius.
Write an inequality that describes T,
the temperatures at which
Sydney wears skirts.
So again, pause this video and see
if you can have a go at that.
Alright. So when does Sydney wear skirts?
When the temperature is warmer
than 25 degrees Celsius.
Now, warmer means that
the temperature is higher
than 25 degrees Celsius,
or that the temperature is
greater than 25 degrees Celsius.
And we're using capital
T to denote temperature.
So we would say capital
T, this needs to be higher
than 25 degrees, or greater
than 25 degrees Celsius.
So T is greater than 25.
Let's do one last example here.
So here we are told that Lola
and Hayley are running a race.
Lola finishes the race in 53 seconds.
Hayley finishes after Lola.
Write an inequality that represents H,
Hayley's finish time in seconds.
Pause the video and see if
you can think about this.
Alright, so how does
Hayley compare to Lola?
Hayley finishes after Lola.
So what does that mean
about Hayley's time?
Well, that means that Hayley
is going to take more time
than Lola to finish the race.
So whatever Lola's time is, Hayley's time
is going to be longer,
or more, or greater than.
So Hayley's time is going to
be greater than Lola's time,
which is 53 seconds,
because Hayley finishes after.